[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cyril tu sors de la salle de bain tout
de suite ça fait deux heures que tu es
dedans homme et je suis pas contre ivan
ramis mongel mais je m'en moque du fera
sans gel change taponnat chronique haut
la barre celui ci là on prend cinq
minutes
bon bah voilà tu as vendu d'où mon petit
saut d'america nom de griffoul
dis moi dommage une très bonne nouvelle
pour soi giboulées patois dîner ah non
je peux pas les verrez il y avaler les
battages après deux mois est ce que tu
fais avec ses couteaux mais je vais
démettre à la cave pas pourquoi bat au
rythme où ça va on va pas tarder à
recevoir thomas une habile art
série mon petit jean je suis rentré là
tu rentres taudis donc sinon il ya qui
sous la douche là tu te manque de mots
quand j'entends culture sous la douche
mais c'est ma mère revient de la boxe
thaï ha voulait prendre une petite
douche oui je sais la maman très bonne
touche bien sûr il ya plus de générer
plus de gel douche et donc est drôlement
chouette amer marines et le box thaï ça
conserve
j'ai fait ça parce semaine dernière j'ai
fait je crois que quand j'étais ma
cousine al akwaa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]